hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Black Panther video so I'm gonna
start with his history in the comics and
then I'm gonna talk about how I think
he's gonna be integrated into the phase
three movies because spider-man's
totally gonna be a part of civil war now
there's a lot of confusion as to how
it's going to affect Black Panthers
screen time so I'll try to explain that
too I'll be doing videos for all the
phase three movies like this but you
guys always send me really awesome
requests so keep doing that I'll include
links for some of those are the movies
in the description below but let's start
at Black Panthers beginning in the last
15 years they've been two really awesome
retellings of the origin story
there's the client storyline by
Christopher priest and then there's the
who is Black Panthers storyline from
Reginald Hudlin and John Romita Jr
Marvel's recommendation engine always
tells everyone to read that second one
the who is Black Panthers storyline just
because it's a little easier for people
that have never read comics before but
if you're really deep into mythology if
you really like that kind of stuff the
Christopher priest run is way better it
just depends on how hardcore you like
your comics to be like if you're
hardcore comic book fan the Christopher
priest run is probably one to go with
but if you have unlimited money and it
doesn't matter just buy them both the
first time he appeared was way back in
1966 in Fantastic Four number 52 he was
the first african-american and comic
book superhero Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
were the ones who created him so you can
totally expect funny Stan Lee cameo
whenever the Black Panther movie comes
in 2018 that seems so far away I have a
feeling at a certain point the like
digitally mapped Stan Lee's face so they
could just put him in whatever movies
they want so after Black Panther
appeared in that Fantastic Four comic he
just he jumped around to a couple
different titles until he joined the
Avengers in 1968 and issue 52 so this is
a big deal because Ultron appeared for
the first time two issues later in
number 50 for the connection between
Black Panther and Ultron is that black
panther has access to vibranium Ultron
wants it although I should say everybody
in the Marvel Universe wants vibranium
as you'd expect that kind of makes
people from Wakanda a little xenophobic
not only is he a member of the Avengers
but he's also like they're politically
ambassador to what I'm expecting is is
it the Phase three movies will slowly
explain this like we'll learn about what
Conda first like it's a place fuller and
vibranium is there and then we'll start
to meet these black panther characters
funfact
black panther is not his name is
just a title given to the current chief
of the Panther tribe at any given time
the person that is Black Panther is the
Panther totem they form a connection
with the Panther deity that gives them
their powers so whenever you take the
mantle you become the new totem on paper
his powers work a lot like Captain
America's like he's super strong super
fast if they were to fight each other on
screen they'd be fairly equal
it's just that Black Panthers powers
come from a mystical source and unlike
Captain America Black Panthers uniform
his suit is a vibranium weave imagine
having a suit made from the same
material the Captain America's shield is
made from yeah it'd be like having
something that's as lightweight as
street clothes but stronger than Iron
Man's armor the twist with all his
powers though is that he has to eat a
special herb to form the connection with
the Panther deity whenever he eats the
herb it activates his powers during that
Christopher priests storyline he got a
bunch of new gadgets and subsequent
writers have done the same thing usually
when new writers take over a comic
they'll give their characters a whole
bunch of new toys to play with Iron Man
is the best example of that so if Black
Panther is such an awesome character why
is Marvel waited this long to introduce
him in the movies well there are a lot
of reasons but mostly because of the
mystical nature of his abilities he also
has the connection with Ultron and
vibranium and they're just now getting
to that an age of Ultron but they
haven't done magic yet they just cast
Doctor Strange he'll bring magic into
the Marvel Universe so to speak and then
they can do Black Panther and they can
explain all the mystical deities stuff
Marvel has been playing it really safe
with the movies they just been like
ramping the craziness up slowly so like
the closest we've come to Magic so far
are the Thor movies and that's really
just super science that looks like magic
when they do get to the Black Panther
movie they're prime mostly gonna go with
that Reginald Hudlin and John Romita Jr
run just because the big villain of that
is Ulysses Klaw and Andy Serkis is
playing that character in age of Ultron
that doesn't mean that Andy Serkis is
going to be the main villain of the
Black Panther movie but it's a pretty
safe bet that he's gonna be in it the
other cool thing about that hublin run
is that it deals with the Black Panther
lineage so you get a historical look at
all the previous Black Panthers remember
it's a title that gets passed down
through the Royal line in the most
current incarnation Black Panther took
the title from his uncle there was a run
in the comics where he passed the title
on to his sister and she became black
panther he's been all over the place
there was even a time
daredevil had him come to Hell's Kitchen
and gave him like like his duties as
daredevil fighting crime in and around
New York City it was like his time in
exile from Wakanda I know that makes
everyone wonder is Black Panther going
to guest star on the daredevil show
probably not in season 1 but there's
always the chance that he could show up
in a cameo in season 2 so if you're
looking for a really easy comic book to
read about Black Panthers origin story
just read that huddle and run but really
I'd recommend you also check out that
priest run too just because it's so
awesome this is a good jumping-off point
for the the Marvel phase 3 films so
here's what Marvel has confirmed so far
chadwick boseman playing the character
not going to appear for the first time
officially till Civil War he's not
listed on the cast list for age of
Ultron but Kevin Feige says we would see
him in the black panther costume in
Captain America Civil War however based
on the age of Ultron trailer it does
look like final boss form Ultron is
going to be made of vibranium so I'm
interested to see how the movie explains
that without explaining Black Panther at
all that now that spider-man's going to
be appearing in Civil War in at least a
minor role the real question is is we
don't know how big his role is and if
it's going to supersede the role that
Black Panther was going to have I don't
think that's gonna happen
they don't start shooting the film till
April until after age of Ultron comes
out so they still have time to finish
rewriting the script I think they had a
version of the script that didn't
include spider-man and once they
confirmed that he was gonna be in it
they probably changed it again
right off the bat they've already said
that Civil War the movie is not gonna be
like Civil War the comic so even though
Spiderman was like the linchpin of civil
war in the comics that doesn't mean that
that's gonna be the case in the movies I
think what's gonna end up happening is
that they'll just balance a little bit
more it's still a Captain America movie
so he'll be the biggest character Robert
Downey jr. will be like the next guy on
the list and then you'll have all the
other characters that Marvel wants to
introduce for the first time black
panther being the biggest one there's
actually a really interesting story
about how Captain America 3 turned into
Civil War because supposedly that wasn't
the first idea that they had Robert
Downey jr. said that because he wanted
to do more movies as Ironman but kind of
felt like it was harder and harder for
him to quarterback his own films the
logical next step was to do a team-up
movie with another big character and
because Captain America was coming up
they had the Civil War storyline they
settled on that down he did say that he
came to marvel with with a couple of
ideas for like the next step for his
character for the army I character so
I'm actually wondering what those other
ideas were civil war was just one of the
things on the list
I think the real reason they settled on
civil war is because they could write it
to be like the next logical step for all
these characters given what happens
during age of Ultron I'm not gonna get
into crazy
age of Ultron spoilers but Civil War
will be the next step from that here's
where things get a little timey wimey
with the phase 3 movies they're not
gonna be linear like the phase 2 movies
Thor 3 and Captain America 3 will both
pick up in the moments after the end of
age of Ultron but when you look at the
schedule Captain America comes out next
year may 2016 Thor 3 isn't coming out
til November 2017 I know it sounds
really confusing but those post-credit
scenes in age of Ultron will completely
set up all those future films it'll
it'll completely make sense I already
made a video for Thor 3 Ragnarok so I
had a link in the description for that
and for those that are asking I know a
lot of you're confused about which
version of Ragnarok it's gonna be it's
actually the Jack Kirby Ragnarok it's
not the Civil War clone Ragnarok the
difference is that the Jack Kirby
Ragnarok is an Asgard shattering event
and the Thor clone is a much smaller
thing here's my big question for you
guys how do you want Marvel to integrate
Black Panther into the Avengers like how
do you want that dynamic to look just
remember that all of the films between
Civil War and Avengers infinity War part
1 are solo titles so we might not see
him in an Avengers team until that first
Avengers 3 film but I totally have faith
in chadwick boseman he's a great actor
so I think it's gonna be a lot of fun I
don't think they've officially confirmed
a writer yet but if you watch arrow Marc
Guggenheim was joking that he wanted to
write the screenplay for it it was kind
of hard to tell whether he was joking or
not but I don't think he would have time
to do a screenplay for a movie if he's
running a show that shoots 180 days a
year so my next Marvel video is gonna be
agents of shield big reminder that comes
back on Tuesday they're going full steam
ahead on Inhumans so be sure to
subscribe to get those weekly videos
it's just it's replacing agent Carter so
I'll be doing weekly videos for it again
while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn about a maybe
spider-man cameo at the end of Avengers
age of Ultron Danny Elfman is just
writing some music for it so they might
have like a teaser for spider-man and
you can click here for that Thor
video thank you so much for watching so
I'll see you guys this weekend high
fives
live long and prosper
you